j'ai été diagnostiqué avec un cancer du
poumon un diagnostic plus qu'inattendu
pour moi étant donné que je n'avais
jamais eu de dossier médical
je n'ai jamais fumé et j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours été en grande forme
physique et plein d'énergie
on sait depuis longtemps que le tabac
est la principale cause de cancer du
poumon que c'est le cancer le plus
fréquent chez les hommes et les femmes
utilisent les plus mortelles mais ce
qu'on sait moins ceux qui n'ont pu mât
comme la ministre nadine giroud peuvent
également être victimes typiquement sa
riche et des gens qui ont qui sont plus
jeunes qui ont qui ont un bon style de
vie qui n'ont pas de défauts majeurs au
niveau de la consommation de drogue ou
d'alcool ou tout ce qu'on peut
s'imaginer comme comme problème qui peut
être associé au cancer
en fait de 15 à 20% des cas de cancer du
poumon survient chez des gens qui n'ont
jamais touché un produit du tabac
seulement aux états unis plus de 20000
non fumeurs décèdent chaque année du
cancer du poumon ce qui en ferait à lui
seul un des dix cancers les plus
meurtriers
la fumée secondaire est bien sûr la
principale cause de ce type de cancer du
poumon mais dans seulement 20 % des cas
les autres coupables
la pollution atmosphérique le gaz radon
qui est un sous produit de l'uranium
l'amiante des substances chimiques comme
l'art ce n'est la fumé du cannabis et
dans bien des cas des facteurs
génétiques
on pense que peut-être une composante
familiale composante génétique les
parlements éléments de malchance aussi
dans ces cancers là en fait un grand
nombre de mouvements qui ont un cancer
du poumon sont porteurs d'un gène
particulier le j fr et la majorité
d'entre eux sont des femmes
ça correspond à peu près à 10% des
cancers du poumon à montréal si on
regarde la fréquence de cette anomalie
la 2g fr à vancouver c'est 30 % des
cancers du poumon si on regarde en asie
au japon en chine c'est 50 % des cancers
du poumon une note positive
les cancers du poumon chez les
non-fumeurs qui ont des causes
génétiques très précise et identifiables
sont ceux qu'on parvient maintenant à
traiter le plus efficacement ici norma
grondin radio canada montréal